I never did this before what's up GQ is
my lot of big lot of and these are my
stitches one thing first and foremost I
cannot live without good so I keep my
own key see that's called arc and that's
the earliest form over across so I keep
that on my shows I pray when we on the
road for we get in the car if you ever
see me and I'm just like this
[Music]
I got a lot of parts this is baccarat
today and this is for rich it smell like
money and good this is my perfume
blowing smoke say I got to you I got
Chanel I start to the side she I got out
it but this is my favorite one cuz it
costs the most it shows in smell this is
the red bottle so it's like more potent
whatever you got more oil in but I got
this one
ain't no long can I reach are you I love
me a booster I got this one week it's
like I said I'm unplugging alone right
here we got a um a Gucci old sheet you
know I'm saying I got another Gucci
today so I brought out the Gucci Gucci I
like to match my bags we would have
outfit I got our own so today we went
with the blue Gucci cuz I got my Gucci
and just writing them don't touch that's
the cash you got some air parts I'm not
going in case could a dirty him I got
Chanel you're sitting in I got a hell of
a season
the government tried to kill me baby
ain't gonna let me get this right here
is my gluten I'm really give me a free
trip because y'all be asking me like
Hobby shining on stage I'm saying this
is this one I got from the 6th or the
state store got the real I don't want
that damn dollar store this this stuff
real deal so you don't saying it's not
good so my but just the liquid version
so you may stick some together and
you're gonna be shining shine bright no
you got a boobies buff at the same time
not some different occasions they for
everyday use I think wearing glitter
highly since I seen myself on stage for
the first time because I was like I want
him to be shining down Julio the shots I
hit a mil I go rock out this is the guy
play with dog I used to dry the hidden
boat sound with your Mexico and they
introduced me to Don Julio my life ain't
been the same since no care it's like he
lying baby and when I feel like going
big on a little bit I get the 1942 but
this everyday
Sampo up when I told in any boat lady I
was on a hinny for a long time till I
made their own tequila boat in Mexico
baby I went down to Mexico I went there
for my 21st birthday and my friend Venus
name soon yeah party different you know
say something like charge me I won't so
today so they put me on this boat and
it's been I've ever seen
[Music]
so when you when you on their own now
Julio bow you got a love of your life
out with some water you think it's
specifically called water they really
need to cut the shape because I beeping
on court water is the best water if you
ask me to water I drink hello water to
be honest if I'm not drinking water then
is some shots at Don Julio but like I
won't drink soda and juicy stuff these
right here are some lashes so usually I
begin my individual me lashes installed
but lately I've been traveling like a
mom so I've been having to do shirts
these is essential I need I'm
light-skinned and I got my natural hair
is blonde my real lashes is blind they
look invisible so I mean these lashes I
like my lashes long and I like my lashes
do this right here is called lace glue
okay this is a beauty supply store latex
glue it gets even stronger Denise the
distant ghost wearing lace glue so when
I be performing I turn I put on actual
show if you ain't been to one of my
shows you need to come out period I turn
so I be sweaty and we might just look
back to the beat but I'm just cleaning
up hit that lace with some days later he
said this what I got with me in New York
right now I can't live without my jury
this is a bus down rolling I had
upgraded my other watch cuz I had it on
just the bezel bus down and everything
was else was start I pushed down put a
pink
and then my chain I bought this when I
was like 19 I like just make me sit me
mean a lot to me because 19 be able to
buy old she was trained with a beat or a
pending on that I like that it's a sign
of success that gave me many deer on my
watch in the NYPD in my time I feel like
Rolex is like the og like him when he
lost and the value and wrote this ain't
going no damn work around for years and
it's gonna be calm we gonna be dropping
that much money on some damn jury I
better hold this before long goddamn
time busting it down I already took the
value down so it be at least a valuable
branding I don't really do that on
trendy I stay with the old she's really
I cannot leave what I want phone that's
why I'm dying right now
do you know I left my phone there over
yesterday and it was driving not
answering the phone
still I went on for him and he had a
phone over 24 hours and I'm itchy I'm
itchin my blood pressure cuff and look
I'm dad listen I can't live without my
phone it's the Grammys like I got
pictures in their phone but it's okay
could we gonna wipe that from we're
gonna race that phone I was trying to
give it a little time but I don't think
I'm getting a phone back and what's in
that phone cannot be seen so that it
will be wiped probably when I leave
he'll wipe clean this it's okay we're
just gonna pray that what's in that
phone is my seat see the internet see
the world listen listen listen if I tell
you
[Applause]
big lotto become when he thank y'all for
watching this was my essentials
[Music]